80
of a human being's inner dialogue is
negative one of the things that human
being sucks at besides dreaming is the
ability to keep promises to ourselves
everyone is listening anytime
that you want to move yourself
from being a chicken brother weather
reporter
or from your lower self you need three
things and it really is that simple
that's really key to your mission
nation we are in for a special treat
today i am i am uh
a little nervous anxious scared excited
we have uh beth hendell in the house
she's got an amazing executive coaching
group and she is going to coach me
on how to make my life better beth
welcome aboard
[Laughter]
first of all evan thank you for the
courage to literally have a first
coaching session ever with me publicly
in front of everybody so that just
speaks who you are and i already adore
you that you're willing to do that and
have that kind of courage so rock on
here we go how i found you was uh on
gary's channel so garyvee you were on a
session with him and he was talking
about how you were his life coach and
and for
for vayner and like gary v has a life
coach what garyvee like is the life
coach how is he having a life coach so
that made me interesting interested in
your world one of the things i struggled
a lot with in my early years and maybe
still do we could dissect it is
asking for help and the willingness to
to
let people in
and um
i struggled a lot with that in my early
business and kind of pretended like i
had it all figured out meanwhile i was
like in
all alone kind of trying to figure
things out and so what i've been trying
to do
on my journey upwards is also to share
as much as i can behind the scenes i've
done therapy sessions i've done
um eft like tapping sessions live uh on
channels i've done hypnotherapy
uh just to show like hey it's okay to
ask for help and it's not as scary as a
lot of people think and so
i'm i'm excited to talk to you i'm
nervous and anxious and we'll see where
it goes but part of it was also to show
we haven't had any pre-talk i don't know
what questions are coming this is a this
is a real session you're going to get to
see behind the scenes and we'll see
we'll see what shows up and um i'm i try
to be an open book as long as i'm not
throwing somebody else under the bus and
uh hopefully it inspires people
obviously to learn more about the handel
group and all the great work and we'll
link that up in the description below
but also um to whatever you're
struggling with you don't have to go
through this alone and there's people
who can help
you
love that anything else evan over to you
beth you asked me what you need to know
and here we go all right all right so
let me give a little back so first
everyone i'm an executive life coach i
have life coaches at handel group but i
um i coach um in business so i was
gary's executive life coach and then for
his senior executives and over 500
people there we did a bunch of work and
in fact i'm the one that created with
him kind candor right because that is
what we started to work on is like how
do you hit
somebody upside the head with the brick
to hold them accountable but do it such
from your heart
that they're not left with you're a jerk
they're left with dealing with
themselves and so
out came kind candor because that's what
we teach all right so here and then
everyone is listening this is not a
normal session okay so just so
everyone's very clear i would never
do this to anybody like just like all
right i don't know you let's go have a
session so normally just so everyone
knows and i appreciate evan and we're
going to get into it is you do our inner
you career module so i have to read all
your homework first so i can then all on
the first session already know your
cavities and your pollution and i can
immediately get to work so i don't know
any of yours so this is a little
backwards
we're doing this okay
all right so
give me something evan that is so
if you take your whole life there's what
you are rocking out what you're proud of
what you're happy about what you're
effective about
that's that world i'm not going to coach
you on any of that because you're
already happy proud and effective in all
those areas
i want an area of your life one or two
that's on mediocre ground like it's not
great you've either tolerated and don't
think it can change you've given up on
that area all right whatever my brother
and i are just never gonna get along so
it could be something you gave up on but
mediocre not happy proud and effective
all right give me an area or two
i think the biggest thing that i
struggle with is
next steps for the business
and i'll oscillate between
three different mindsets i've i've heard
you know in your videos and having the
dream like what is your dream i don't
have a specific quantifiable dream
um i have a mission of what i'm trying
to
accomplish
and
inside of that there are there are three
states one is i'm doing exactly what i
need to be doing this is amazing like
youtube is the answer i want to solve
the world's biggest problem people don't
believe in themselves enough that's what
i wake up trying to do every day and
some days i feel like
this is exactly youtube is the way we've
hit half a billion people i just need to
keep going we're crushing it
some days the second state would be
uh i need to i'm just going to be open
and see what comes and and not try to
force it because great opportunities
will come like even like this you know
today is a day like that like hey my
channel grew we got connected here we
are doing this amazing thing
and then and then the third state would
be i don't know what to do next i don't
know what the next step is
not am i doing the wrong thing but
it's easy to keep going with what i'm
doing what's the next big thing that i
need to take
all
right
yeah
no no finish your sentence i apologize
oh just just lack of clarity on
the next step it's like the big picture
but then the big picture seems too big
and
nobody else has kind of done it
the way i want to do it but i don't know
the way i want to do it and so that
could be that could be a positive like
let's go and exciting it could also be a
negative like oh okay but what do i
actually do next i'm going to show you
something completely different than
because what happens people is when
you're you have an area of your life
that isn't
um that you don't have clarity in or
you're not happy proud effective and
it's like mediocre we come up with our
own theories of why it's like that
and then if it's the wrong theory we're
stuck so i'm gonna try something
completely different to give you another
avenue and access into it okay yeah
great
so i'm gonna speak for a few minutes
everybody and teach everyone a principal
at handel group that we teach
um
so you do your dreams and you can hear
evan for sure has a dream it's a he
calls it a mission it's a dream like and
if you were to say it in one sentence
evan what's your mission
i want to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough
okay beautiful so you are solving people
believing in themselves enough and your
love of humanity and god damn it i want
you to believe in yourself and then okay
but what do i do next should i do this
this and this all right so now here we
go
so the first thing that we always have
humans do in handheld method is the
dream he's got a dream
so then the next thing we do is oh
welcome to your lower self that's going
to mess with your dream and get you all
weirded out and what to do so i'm now
going to get into the lower self that
comes in
when one has that dream in fact you
could hear a sentence slip out one of
your cavities slipped out let's go where
it was like ready it was my dream might
be too big
okay
that's a cavity so you're already what
i'm calling ready i'm gonna curse manif
your dream
because you're already oh my god maybe
it's too big who am i to think that i
could get that done i need to maybe a
smaller dream no
something else why did that lower self
come in all right so everyone i'm going
to teach you something now so the
question is
what's the source of results
so every result a human being has in
their life whether it's a great result
or whether it's a result you do not want
there's a source to it and most human
beings would answer the question like we
all know the source of all results are
your actions you got to be effective in
your actions you got to take the right
actions it's actions actions actions and
then if you're not producing what you
want obviously you're not taking the
right actions or you're not effective
and everyone goes to work on the
doing-ness of it which is what your
question is what do i do next okay so
now watch
so if the source of results is in action
what is the source of results okay get
ready everyone
your inner dialogue
your thoughts
your thoughts
most of which are in your subconscious
give you your actions and give you your
results
and so dr david hawkins years ago did a
study
of human beings in her dialogue their
thoughts and here's what he discovered
there's two numbers
eighty percent of a human being's inner
dialogue is negative
eighty percent of the stuff in your head
that you're talking smack about is
negative and watch this
95
of your 80 that's negative is the same
thought yesterday
so you didn't like you didn't think
something new like when i i'm 63 years
old when i get naked and look at my body
my voice goes oh you're falling down
that's not a new thought i've been
having that thought since i've been 59
right so it's
negative
gives you your actions results all right
so what we did at handel is we named the
80 percent negative and this is where
i'm gonna have you start to go to work
i'm gonna give you the three names
everybody and then i'll explain them so
one of the voices that makes up your 80
negative is your chicken voice
that's the avoider that's the voice that
says
am i doing the right stuff for my
mission
i don't know maybe i should do this well
maybe i should do this i don't know i'm
confused i don't know what to do that
would be the chicken voice okay okay
that you avoid some people are chickens
about going to the dentist because they
don't want to you know deal with their
teeth right like it's something you're
avoiding okay
but when you're being a chicken evan you
don't know you're being a chicken i'm
going to give you
um one of the clients i'm allowed to
speak about is justin pugh justin pugh
is an nfl um player when i got him he
was a rookie on the giants about to be
cut and he will tell you this exact same
story he has
um and i saved him we got him a contract
on the giants he got on the leadership
council there and then he then got a
contract for 43 million dollars at the
arizona cardinals okay so and he's
engaged he's about to get married in
half a second and has the greatest life
then he will tell you that it came from
me and here's the text i got from him
and it's got a curse in it
beth i thought of you today i had to
speak at the state senate of arizona and
he sent me the clip and he did really
well and then he wrote beth my chicken
didn't want me to do it but i told him
so that's the chicken everybody so
everyone who's listening and evan
included because you're gonna have to
tell me where you're a chicken shortly
okay so you got the chicken then you got
the brat voice
the brat is like my 20 year old teenager
right my 20 year old daughter um 20
years old not a teenager but
and it's like a teenager voice i don't
want to you can't make me you're not the
boss of me leave me alone drop dead die
so it's the brat the brats like the one
when you get up in the morning and
you're supposed to go meditate and your
bra goes not today go back to sleep and
you think god just talked to you no
that's the brat
the defiant one and then evan the last
voice we have is the weather reporter
the weather reporter i'm in costa rica
so sorry i have beautiful weather it's
88 degrees and sunny
right and it's just the facts and all i
can do is dress accordingly period so
weather reporter is the facts but when
someone's weather reporting in their
life they swear their excuse is a fact
so evan if you say to me beth i have no
time to meditate
you think i have no time is as real as
it's cloudy and 45 degrees
it's not so the weather reporter is your
excuse maker all your excuses you use to
justify not taking an action
the brad is the defiant one gets you off
the hook and the chicken also gets you
off the hook it's the avoider
these are your advisory board welcome to
your board of directors evan news on
your advisory board and guess what they
can never be fired
and the other thing about them is their
entire waking existence is to mess you
up
they are not on your team
they will never be on your team that is
not you talking to you nor is it god
talking to you it is your lower self
talking to you and you've got to be able
to meet your chicken bread and weather
reporter to be able to get out of them
and then i'm going to teach you one
other thing after you and i do this
exercise now okay so
okay
now here's what you're going to do
you're going to now take a moment and
tell me where are you a chicken
where are you a brat in your life let's
just start with chicken and brat so
where are you a chicken and where are
you a brat
so chicken is probably easier
historically has been
i'm shy introverted
uh and so i can't be
that person
so
before going on a stage and speaking
before making a video
um
before doing something like this
you know i i
especially like 10 years ago i would
never have done this
and it's like what is she going to ask
me i don't know we're going to do this
live oh my gosh this is crazy exactly he
was talking to you this morning right he
was like oh what's she going to ask me i
don't know oh my god i can't believe i'm
doing this live blah blah blah and in
fact you're keep going you're doing
great keep going i i've uh
gotten better at catching it compared to
before but i'm sure it still shows up in
in a lot of subconscious ways that i'm
not aware of but when i do catch you
back into what you said in the beginning
which is am i doing what i should keep
doing with youtube should i just be open
and see what happens i don't know what
to do
is that what is that is that a chicken
uh you said the chicken is am i doing
the right stuff so
chicken is the avoider so if you keep
going ooh what should i do you see you
have a vision i'm sorry you call it a um
a mission
and it's an incredible mission right to
like have everyone freaking fulfill on
believing in themselves right which
includes you
and so there's places right so there's
places right where you don't believe in
yourself
and i'm accusing you of that in the
trying to figure out what to do next for
your mission
right like you're like you're doing
unbelievable you have three points like
it's crazy good
right so when you start to go oh am i
doing all the right things should i be
doing anything different should i change
it up what should i be doing i want you
to start to hear that that you're
beginning to question yourself versus
trusting yourself
yes definitely question myself
uh
i i struggle with trying to figure out
what is the best path for me
to do it in
my way in that i see obviously gary's
doing his thing and grant's doing her
thing and his thing and oprah's doing
her thing etc and
i
i believe i can do my way but i don't
know what my way is
um and struggle with the path on how to
do it
um
on the worst days right like we're
talking about the worst days the
scenario three where i'm not sure about
the path forward um
worry about uh
maybe this is weather reporter but
running out of time like
what have i done in the past year that's
really moved the needle forward um
on the worst days it could be like okay
well i grew another
half a million subscribers this year or
whatever but i could be doing more what
is what is the more what is the impact
yeah so all that is your lower self
talking to you okay all that keeps you
stuck
because by the time you're through that
loop of the conversation about oh my god
am i too behind maybe i should be i
should have done this years ago what
have i done lately what am i doing this
year all that worry
has you not have to take an action
because you just engage in the worry
right and the questioning and then not
believing in yourself so that which
you're committed to giving the human
race
you've got to start to go to war on
where you don't give it to yourself
because you that's all questioning worry
means you're not believing if you
believed in something would you be
worried
exactly like
right like if you believed in you know
your relationship is madly in love with
you are you worried right no of course
not so the only time we get worried is
if we're really not believing except the
most important thing which is what
you're teaching is believing
so the moment you start to worry you're
now in what's called your negative
dialogue of not believing and it will
mess you up because it's like evan
getting on a train
from like grand central to connecticut
which is like an hour ride you're going
on that train like oh my god do i know
what to do maybe i shouldn't be doing
this maybe i should do more maybe i'm
not ahead enough maybe i'm not
so you engage in that which then gets
you paralyzed and you don't have to take
an action
does that make sense say what you hear
with that
i'm kind of running through what what
would my typical loop be when i'm when
i'm in a moment like that um it would be
you know it hasn't been enough i'm not
i'm not hitting anywhere close to the
potential it's only been you know xyz
um i so then it goes to problem solving
like i don't get stuck and worry and
like oh what do i this isn't like weeks
on end it's more okay well what do i
need to do
i usually
usually don't get an idea of what to do
sometimes i do and then we do something
i usually don't get an idea of what to
do and so to pull myself out it'll be
just keep doing what you're doing
because opportunities will come and i'll
remember like this interview or
something else
exactly
right like it's basically you go like
this i'm gonna do it my way you
basically tell your voice your chicken
your brat who's now going out maybe
you're not you know you're way behind
everybody else right all that is
basically you're going shut the frig up
shush up you and then you trust yourself
again and back in
i'm doing great
let's see what shows up
and you trust now let me teach you
something do you know manifesting
have you heard of manifesting yes
okay all right
what you're do when you are inside of a
dream and believing in your dream the
worst thing that kills a dream
is needing to know how
okay everybody thinks
you gotta know how so you create this
huge dream you created a huge dream
that's worthy of your life right and
then you're like yeah but how am i gonna
do that the moment you go into how you
just dropped from up here in the trees
in your dream
down to in the world versus of the world
and you're now down here trying to
figure out how to do it and it kills the
dream okay
so
it really is inside of neville godard is
who i say is the inventor of manifesting
he was born in 1905.
it might be 1903 but let's go with 1905.
did manifesting and created it in the
1930s and he was from um he's also from
barbados and one of the things they did
in one of his lectures that i have is
basically
screw the house it kills it every single
time
right where you do best is you come back
to believing and trusting and letting it
come to you
versus when you go into your lower self
lower self is always how am i going to
do this how am i going to do this how am
i going to do this
now you got to just stay in the dream
and believe it when you get worried now
know worry equal not believing
that's all you have to go oh i'm worried
therefore i'm not believing this is
happening now okay let's get back to
believing who i am and my mission and
all i'm going to accomplish how i'm
going to do it i don't know how let's
see what the universe gives me today
because manifesting is your relationship
with source
and in your relationship with source
let's source do some of the work
right you don't have to do it all source
is there to help it wants to help
all right so now where are you a brat
consciously i guess it'd only be if i
had you know i was really tired i had a
really rough
sleep i had some
something explode in my business or life
um
i don't feel i live a lot in brat like i
i feel like i live more in chicken
no no no no that's listen it's it's
quite possible i'm
more of a brat than a chicken but
everyone is different sometimes people
are chicken at work and bratty at home
in their personal life
so you're looking so i'll ask a question
so
one of the things that human being sucks
at besides dreaming is the ability to
keep promises to ourselves
we suck at that um and
so is there any place where you created
a dream like meditating eating
exercising um cleaning out the closet
whatever so whatever you created where
in your life don't you keep the promise
that you have
on a regular basis
you're not consistent anyplace
not really um
i think if i'm a brat it's more so one
i'm very like if i say i'm going to do
something to myself i have if it's in my
calendar i have to do it it's like just
built that identity in if i'm going to
brat it's more like if somebody tells me
to do it
maybe wait give me an example who might
tell you to do something
um
i don't know i'm trying to like if you
told me to do something
i my intention coming in is hey i'm
gonna be pushed probably i hope and and
i might get into uncomfortable waters so
let's try to keep an open mind
because i don't want to i don't want the
brat to show up to say no beth like i
got it i'm doing this and your way sucks
and i'm going to keep doing that right
so
um
if somebody tells me what to do
i mean maybe
yeah maybe i mean i probably do it in a
nice way you know canadian humble kind
of side comes out
instead of aggressive new yorker
swearing at people but but it would
still the result would still be like i'm
not doing that thing just because
somebody wants me to do it i'm doing
what i want to do
um
so you get defiant that way so there's
there might be if someone tells you what
to do and then you'll be nice will you
say will you be fake and go oh that's
great thank you
yes and pretend you're going to do it or
do you go no thank you i'm not going to
do it that way
uh
uh
i guess it depends on the relationship
right like if it was somebody if if
somebody close to me i wouldn't fake
that i'm gonna do it
if something i wouldn't have to see
again i might be a little more like okay
thank you and like i just don't want to
engage in a discussion to prove to them
or anything so all right
all right so chicken so your chicken is
um specifically where you can not always
and for everyone who's listening i'm not
thinking evan is 24 7 worried our lower
self comes in under certain
circumstances when our lower self comes
in is in worry fear
um and overwhelm and stress so like you
said if you don't get great sleep you
can get bratty you can get chicken right
so it's not 24 7 ever right human beings
were great and then we suck where we
suck and so
there's we're going for the cavity of
your chicken that we want to take out of
your mission because given that your
mission is having people believe in
themselves we've got you're likely evan
your work is always about dealing with
where you don't believe in yourselves
and then giving it to your audience to
help them with believing in themselves
that's one of the greatest ways to do it
is you're in it with them versus you're
above them i'm in it like with all my
clients all my clients know what sucks
about me right like i'm not pretending
oh i got my together in everything
there's where i'm great and there's
where i need help well that's why i want
to make this video public right it's
like hey here's
see my journey where i don't believe and
yeah i honestly struggled a lot with
this myself earlier on it's like hey um
how are you the believe guy when you
don't believe in yourself for things
it's like well it's it's a never-ending
like you never fully believe in yourself
and it's an ongoing battle and in
hearing those comments i get how people
could think it and it's led me down a
journey of
uh and going the opposite way instead of
pretending like i have it all figured
out let me go all the way behind the
curtains and just
see how i suck and let's let's learn
together
awesome i love it all right so i'm going
to give you another principle everyone
is listening okay
get ready this is a good one
whatever you believe you prove
okay so that you wanna and if you're
gonna steal that from me just say i got
this from hand elbow whatever you
believe
you prove
now that's really key to your mission
because what you're teaching people is
to believe in themselves and evan you
have to know that as human beings in
module two of inner you in any one of
our interviews we have people
take
in their dreams what are they currently
believing because whatever you believe
you're going to prove and we have
negative beliefs that we're proving
so if you take a look right like it
could really be like um i'm 63 so i
could have a belief and i'm single right
i i'm 60 i'm too old i'll never find my
soul mate or he'll never find me right i
could believe that i just don't i'm very
clear i'm gonna have a great love story
it's just mine took longer than most
people it's all right right so whatever
you believe you prove so i want you to
take a look at
there really is evan that you are this
accomplished and making this much of a
profound difference to over millions of
people's lives you really do believe
that you've got something to contribute
to people how do i know that because
look at what you're doing
so i know you have that belief
you also have negative beliefs that's
the ones we want to go after is what are
you believing
that you should stop proving because
whatever you believe you prove and
you're believing something about your
worry or about your dream like oh i need
to know the next steps or it's not going
to go well you must have in your
subconscious a belief that's keeping you
stuck in that
worry do you know what it is
i was going somewhere else but this is
this is good um
why am i worried about
being able to accomplish more so i fully
i'm just talking out loud maybe you
catch something no let it riff i fully
acknowledge that i'm i'm taking on
something so big that i'm never going to
do it
and i don't see that as a negative but
if you want it it's like if you say no
that is a big negative awesome i see it
as like a positive like i've got
something to do for the rest of my life
and yeah you have a legacy no no no no
like in your lifetime will the seven
billion people all believe in themselves
in your lifetime i don't know but you'll
sure as hell gonna make a friggin dent
in it
yeah that's the goal right it's like
it's never going to be accomplished
so i don't hear that as a negative keep
going okay i'm also not legacy driven so
like what do you want people to remember
but when you die i don't know i'm dead i
don't care like it's what am i doing
while i'm alive so it's not about
statues of evan or whatever it's more
about the work that i'm doing just
talking out loud it feels like
i want to one
feel the fulfillment of the work and
feel like
what i do today matters is going to have
an impact on at least one person and
anytime i feel the connection to the
work that i'm doing
always feels great
um and then two feel like
i'm uh
i'm seeing this out like wasting time i
guess i don't i don't feel like i say
that to myself but maybe i am because
it's coming out now
let's see try this one the one i can
hear
that you have a belief in that got us
into this conversation see if this fits
is i must know how to do it
i need to know how to do it
smart people know how to do it
you have something in there where for
some reason you really do believe that
you need to know how to do the next
thing
i guess so yeah potentially yes um i
don't know about like
smart people know how to do it and i'm
not smart i wouldn't i wouldn't
i wasn't saying that um but if it came
out like that i apologize that was not
what i was accusing you of no no that's
fine
see it and then if it doesn't fit you
tell me that i'm just checking i
i get stuck on the how for sure
i i don't
i don't feel like it's me being
frustrated that i don't i guess i don't
know the how but not judging myself for
not knowing the how it's i want to solve
this thing and i want to feel like for
me i'm trying to go a layer above it or
behind it or below it i don't know um
like why even care about
that
because there you go right so but that's
what i'm i don't know
why do i care so much about even having
that as a question
that i have to figure that next thing
out
um
it would be more like if you were freed
up in not needing to know how we're
worried it would be more like when you
wake up in the morning in your designing
of your day you would be like oh my god
i'm so excited to see what the universe
brings me today to fulfill on the next
million people believing in themselves
so it's more of you getting
the
such a belief in yourself and not an
arrogance at all just i know who i am
and what i'm doing for people
and knowing that deeply and knowing that
the universe will always deliver
your answer
okay so that's interesting so
but that's a shift you'd have to
remember whatever you believe you prove
you know one of the things that i took
on believing when we first started
handel group is that you can literally
change
a bad trait of a human being in six
weeks
i made that up and then i started to
prove it and then you know charge people
for it right
so
go ahead you got it
so just staying in that vibe for a
second uh
i don't
live there so this is maybe like
manifestation layer or um when i said
there's like three three places where i
live
the whole i'm doing great and things
will open up to me and it will present
themselves is not where i live it's my
coping mechanism to get me out of
when i feel low
whoa
but that is what you want to start to
believe and prove that's where i want to
live
that's where you want to live it's not a
coping mechanism it's actually a new
belief that you took it on as oh my new
belief is i'm doing great i just have to
be open and the universe will deliver i
believe that and i'm going to prove it
and then i'm going to give you how to
prove it shortly but yeah if you dig
that one yes that would be the shift
you don't need it as a coping mechanism
you just need that as your tagline so to
speak
right of yeah
i it always delivers given i'm doing
great and i always get the answers from
the universe some version in there yeah
go ahead i can see you thinking so no i
like i mean i'm yeah i like it i i have
to
it feels right so that's good um
i want you to say it out loud again to
make sure it feels right
you think of the wording i don't really
use words like universe and stuff so i
mean maybe i should maybe like just
use your words yeah yeah i'm trying to
think what i said what did i say the sec
for the second state of where i live
you actually said be open and see what
happens but you can make it a little
sexier than that yeah exactly right it's
like
i'm i'm
doing the right thing i don't know
what's coming next and
something great is coming
so yeah something great is coming the
right thing trusting
i think that might be a key word for you
trusting
you your trusting source will deliver
trusting it will give me the answer
trusting so doing i'm doing the right
thing trusting
yeah
trusting what trust the great things
will come
there you go yeah yeah
do you believe that
uh i do yeah i do i don't live there but
i do like when i oh hi that's what
coaching is is my job is to get you into
a new operating state
then you have to prove
so
and i've only just put you there right
we just placed you there for you know so
you got like your you got your toe in
there right so it's a new state you
haven't lived in that's why we have to
prove it because we've got you believing
it rock on that's the first step and
everyone who's listening
when you go to come up with a new belief
because whatever you believe you prove
the question you ask yourself after you
say it is do i believe that
if you don't 100 believe it you're not
going to prove it
because whatever you believe you prove
including if you have someone on your
team that you think is a jerk you will
prove that and i'll tell you to fire
that person like what are you waiting
for so if you think you're a jerk it's
over
whatever you believe you prove it's one
of the greatest gifts of human being
and then you just got to pay attention
to what you're proving
right i started to prove as i was
getting older that i'm fragile that is
not something i should prove i then
fractured my ankle right like no let's
not prove i'm turning fragile right so
now i hike six days a week to prove i'm
not fragile i am beast right and i've
shifted it all what do you do oh hike
you hike hike yes so now i'm going to
shift you into let's prove it okay okay
so
so everyone who's listening anytime
that you want to move yourself
from being a chicken brother weather
reporter
or from your lower self you need three
things and it really is that simple
i'm going to say the three things and
i'll explain them you need a specific
measurable promise
you need a
consequence and you need someone to hold
you to account
so if you're being a chicken about your
work
right and not believing in yourself you
would then make a specific measurable
promise like okay every day i will call
three people from my contacts and ask
them who they know for a job for me
so it's a specific measurable promise
it's specific and measurable and it will
get you out of being a chicken brother
weather reporter or a warrior or
whatever it is
so then after you make the specific
measurable promise given that we suck at
keeping promises to ourselves evan's
pretty good at it but still given it's a
new state
you need a consequence and the
consequence is
something silly or annoying that you
have to pay if you don't keep the
promise
and then you always need someone to hold
you to account because we'll lie to
ourselves
so evan what we could do is i'm going to
create with you
making a promise with a consequence i
can hold you to account for sure your
listeners can definitely hold you to
account right
um and then we could do if you wanted
like i come back in a month to see how
you're doing right and did you keep that
promise or did you have to pay the
consequence so that'll be up to you okay
yeah all right so what we're looking for
is to prove
that the trusting great things will come
and to start to do damage to when your
worrier comes up
okay so when your worrier starts
doubting you oh my god what are you
going to do next you have nothing to do
i've sat here for three days and nothing
has come to me oh my god maybe this is
wrong and beth is full and she's not
really a good coach because i don't
right you go okay so
we're looking for a promise so now i'm
going to give you one of mine because
it's way easier in the beginning to
promise like how many times a week will
you exercise or meditate or you know
only have two glasses of wine not six so
when we get into personality or we get
into like trusting the great things will
come
right
it's the same thing a promise
consequence and someone will hold your
account but it's a little different so
i'm going to give you one of mine one of
my bad traits evan is i can i i'm a
doomser
what's a doozy i do a doomsa i doomsday
oh doomser okay
i get it from my mother
more than my dad but my mother for sure
and we teach you epigenetics and we get
everything for our parents so i'm a
doomsayer and it's so embarrassing i'm
going to tell you the story like i will
literally i have been sorry this is
awful again remember i'm a doomser like
i'll have been to
when i was married to my you know and i
loved him and we're we have a great
divorce we're dear friends he trains me
at his gym i used to dooms like he would
die because i could get scared about
that he'd die and i'd be at his funeral
and what would i say so i've been to
many people's funerals who are still
living right because i dooms it right i
will dooms my daughter and i um i don't
ride horses anymore i did for eight
years my daughter still does oh my god
she has gotten paralyzed many a day
right like i dooms things
to the universe don't hear me now right
so i'm a doomser and so um years ago i
made a promise
because i don't want to be sitting in
dooms and i don't want to manifest
myself into doomsing something is i have
my promises from the moment i hear
myself doomsing i have one minute to
shut her down or i gotta start throwing
ten dollar bills out my car window okay
so that's mine i've only had to ever pay
once and never again and i made this
promise like over ten years ago and
literally evan if you watched me you
know if i start doomsing you will watch
me have one minute to do but like some
days i'll go like if i'm driving look at
the trees beth look at the trees look at
the trees don't doom sing no don't think
no don't think no like i literally have
to do violence to it because she wants
me to go there
my lower self and i'm not going to and
i'm not going to pay the 10 bucks but i
will if i have to
so yours is going to be similar to mine
some version of the moment you hear
yourself start engaging in the worry
conversations oh my god should i be
doing this nothing i don't know what to
do maybe i should have you know those
worried conversations what if i don't
know the answer to that you know what
i'm talking about
can i take it in a slightly different
direction than you tell me if i'm just
way off base so rock on go ahead okay so
for the execution i'm like you give me
homework i'll do the homework like i'm
i'm i'm the ex of the strengths i'm an
executor i get it done it's in my
calendar i'll tell my wife or not tell
my audience or not like whatever it's
happening because i said i was going to
do it and like i built like that that's
a pat on my own shoulder for like i will
get that stuff done i love that um but
like what do i get done that's more the
the how so i i feel like
what you're describing i can definitely
get better at catching it and i'm
using the coping mechanism i see it as a
coping mechanism to shift out of it uh
and i i could be faster then and what
you presented is amazing validation like
hey what you're doing is actually the
right thing and now get faster at doing
it
so this is where i can shift consciously
to do it what i
am
i think would be like a huge
breakthrough for me is to figure out how
do i
not just like when i catch myself being
the doomsa or my version of it
the warrior the warrior but to live
there it's not my default state
so what do i need to is it do i need to
12 times a day set an alarm and manche
myself into like how do i make it my
default state as opposed to just when
the warrior shows up
so you're asking me let me see if i
track it you want the default state to
be open and do it trusting and getting
things done so you want trusting to be
your new state
yeah
okay very good there's two things which
is what we teach we teach you how to
replace
how do you leash as in like a dog leash
the negative side which is the worrier
and then how do you replace it with
trusting like a new like a new
a positive one right so you're leashing
the worrier
and you're replacing it with trusting is
that an accurate statement is there a
middle like
i don't live in warrior mode
but i don't live in dark side does your
dart when he shows up
you definitely know that's what i'm
talking about so he shows up and you
start worrying like
what should i do what should i do what
should i do some version of that okay
that's the warrior you can call him
something else but that is the one that
starts that's the lower self mm-hmm but
we need to you have to do two things
evan you have to leash him
and you have to replace it so when i
replaced so one of my bare traits is on
um
used to be very mean
um a complete [ __ ] and i had to leash
her
because that's not nice
right and i then replaced her with my
heart and love i had to do both i had to
do things to like i had to be on like if
i was mean i owed you money and an
apology and then i was also working on
my love and each day doing something to
bring her forth but it's both evident
okay so inside of that example i i love
it feels really applicable
you have your mean state which is not
where you're living like maybe that's 10
of the time or whatever circumstance is
great
it's by exception only because i've
leased her very well so every so often
maybe
once a month maybe usually not i could
like have a little
so it used to be like a bigger number
and now it's down to tiny right all the
time exactly so and then there's love
but you're not but that's like the ideal
state but it's not
at least maybe it is now but it wasn't
where you were living you weren't living
in mean but you weren't living in
positive either
total [ __ ] i was my construct was [ __ ]
we had a leisure it wasn't 24 7.
remember bad traits only come out under
stress overwhelm or fear right so my
mean would come out when it came out
so i leashed her and had a promise and a
consequence about that
and at the same time i was bringing
forth my love my heart my sweetness my
kindness and i had a promise about that
right i had both because
what i was really working on was
bringing love in
but i had to get consequenced if i was a
[ __ ]
so you're really making sure the warrior
is not allowed
he's not allowed in your day he will
show up because it's part of your
humanity and so we're we're leashing him
like when he shows up you're like yep no
thank you
i got one minute to shut you down not
allowed be quiet and then replacing it
we'll give you an action we're going to
come up with a promise inside of the
world of trusting so that becomes your
new state
okay
people who now meet me would not know
that they could get i'm a [ __ ] because
i'm you know in new york
right but no one has that experience of
me anymore because i'm not that girl
right that's very rare right it's by
exception so i live more in the love
state obviously now than i did so we're
bringing forth a new state but we got to
make sure the worry is leashed so it's
both evan okay
so to like narrow in on that and but you
know apologize for being slow at like
picking this up no you're this is for
everyone who's listening this is every
now this is a big deal no slow so when
you your first question to me was where
do you feel like you're being mediocre
pick an area of your life
yes
this feels like a full circle moment at
least to me where
mediocre is just average you're not
great you're not terrible it's just it's
just meh
so
i feel like the warrior state
is definitely there but
10 of the time good the uh the abundance
like
great things are coming to me
is
definitely not default state either it's
just coping mechanism where am i living
i'm living not in in
uh
warrior i'm living in mediocre i'm
living in like okay just keep going like
planning planning like what am i doing
next i'm living and i'm usually happy
with that mode
so
i think the big
if you go from warrior to abundance i'm
actually already doing that as my coping
mechanism how do i go from
not warrior but mediocre
evan
day-to-day evan and turn him into
abundant seven does that make sense
yes what you want to start to prove is
the new state of abundance and believing
because all we're talking about is your
mediocre state is where you don't
believe
we can call it the warrior we can call
it there's a moment and yes it's only 10
but the 10 is what we're going after
right is that you
it's a place where a
the loop of the negative dialogue of
like am i doing okay am i doing fast
enough am i doing that's what we even
though it's ten percent we can't let him
live anymore that that part of your
lower self has got to die
okay and we're bringing in a new called
abundance trusting and i know who i am
yeah so what i if i could like label
those three things i think of my default
state is like believing in the plan
okay
and that's where i live and that's what
i'm doing like i wake up i follow my
calendar it's why i'm like very calendar
focused i believe in the plan i'm doing
the plan i'm actually you tell me to
shift my plan i will do it beth i'm
believing in the plan because beth told
me to do it until i prove otherwise it
doesn't work
so believe in a plan is like 80 percent
of my life is like that's where i
default live yes that 10 15 might be no
belief like what am i even not what am i
doing like forget this whole thing but
like i stopped believing in the plan
and i don't know what the plan is
and then and then my coping is my i call
it coping mechanism but i unleash myself
and the leash could be tighter i mean i
have a leash that then takes me to
abundance to say
not belief in the plan but belief in
things will just work out belief in
universe belief in whatever oh i got it
so what you're a master of
is you're a master which most humans
aren't i'm a master of this too this is
a very this is a unicorn
you really are a master in your doing
this in honoring your calendar and doing
what you say that is unusual
okay that's a unicorn okay except here's
where i can hear you get in trouble now
is
you're a master of doing this and
calendar and plan i want to play and
that's in the world that's like down
here
i want you back up in the trees
yeah where you're flying from the trees
where your dream is your vision is your
mission is
you have to live up here you're one of
those creative geniuses that needs to
live up here gary vee lives up here my
sister lives up here my sister's trying
to get me to live up here right because
i'm a master like you and doing this
calendar structure is organized do the
plan do the plan except
the plan is not what you wake up for you
wake up for what yeah
your dream
but you don't wake up in your dream you
wake up in your calendar
and you're a master of that so you can
like we don't even have to worry about
you letting that go it's the same as me
you and i probably the same calendar we
are masters of it what we need to get
great at
is staying in
the
the dream in the genius of that dream
and who you are as an icon who's
bringing forth believing for the planet
you've got to stay up there
and up there's way different that
doesn't mean don't go to your calendar
and see what you have to do today okay
but it's more we got to get you spending
more time up in the trees yeah so if
we're going to put a leash like we've
got a leash on
on
super negative self-worth evan it could
be a tighter leash and give me a great
strategy to like make that leash tighter
but
i have a leash but i have zero leash on
on planning yeah you're not bringing
forth you're who you are okay so what we
need is the replacement of the
you're not replacing being a master of
the of the
physical so to speak okay you're a
master of the physical
which
hello everyone who's listening here you
want to get masterful in your doing this
like he is because that's harder
than the other okay so that's awesome so
what we're creating now evan is a
promise
of what you're gonna do as a specific
measurable promise daily or at least
monday through friday
that's gonna have you living up in the
trees
even if you said that i hate that you i
hate like in my my own voice that you
hedged like took it down now it has to
be daily because you said it and then
knocked it down like at the achiever and
he's like no beth we're going
all right whatever daily want okay so
now it's some version of um
so living up here so watch
i just put myself in a crazy promise
starting today my promise and
consequences today which is i'm going to
say this new thing that we're starting
to um invent which is being high
on your own supply
being high on evan's supply
like
oh my god you're high on your supply
you're the best evan it's like your
electrified delay like you're touching
the wire and producing crazy so watch
what i have to do
because i got a little boring and so i
brought back who i had invented myself
to be years ago called it's a curse
wildly impressive
and having that spiritual breakthrough
so i could live up here so watch what my
promise is
every day if i'm not if i don't have
insane magic of like
high on my supply like on the wire
electrified like that kind of magic i
don't get my netflix tonight
so i'm in costa rica for three months um
with two sisters and a brother-in-law i
work here um i'm up very early in the
morning and between like 6 30 and 8 30 i
watch my shows and go to sleep okay
watch i don't get my tv shows tonight
unless i was high on my supply which
means living up here and being wildly
magical with things and i already did it
by aiden this morning because over my
dead body am i not getting my tv
i already created and i've got four
things that i'm already high on my
supply so what if we created with you
evan
that each day
some version of high on your supply like
the magic that the universe delivered
today without you doing much
or you don't get whatever your vice is
right tv a glass of wine at the end like
you have to earn your wine or your vice
like we play in the game of
what you've got to produce so that
you're at your highest self
so now talk back to me about that yeah
so a couple things i mean the earning
really is
earning i want to earn the point that i
did it you know like i want to earn my
seven days that it's in the calendar i
want to earn that and if i said i was
gonna do it and i didn't check it off
like that
feeling eats at me more than losing like
a show or something yeah but you can't
go you can't now beat yourself up if you
lost today right you got to like you
can't also beat yourself up i don't beat
myself up all right i don't get tv i'll
be better tomorrow right yeah yeah for
sure for sure i don't i don't live in
that world i don't live in like you suck
you've got to be high on your supply you
have to have so been swinging from the
trees in abundance and believing that
the universe delivered something that
was like
you can't wait to tell your wife
right like oh my god look what happened
today
just because you
are believing in yourself and swinging
from the trees in your dream and that
doesn't mean you answered the question
what should i do today
because you have your calendar it
already gives you what to do i had no
clue when i woke up this morning i was
giggling a little and also a little
scared like oh
the game starts today what if i don't do
it i'm like shut up that's just shut up
and i'm like well what should i do
because i have an entire calendar today
that has nothing to do with you know my
being high on my supply i got coaching i
got you i got this i got like no time
like to sit and like what should i do to
be high on my support and by eight
o'clock
the universe was delivering stuff to me
and i had a call and then i created it
with that person that i didn't even know
i was going to then the next call i
created this other wild thing i'm like
oh my god i'm high on my supply yeah as
you were saying it where my head was
going okay i i need to schedule it in
which i can do morning routine there it
is it's going to be there and every day
for the rest of my life i can do that
right perfect it'll get done but then
where my head immediately went
afterwards like i need
examples of what to do because i've got
i think of ideas like so the planner
starts coming out immediately like okay
well how do i do it so if i go mad and
think about this opportunity here for me
is like oh my gosh what's beth gonna ask
me
you know but like how amazing is this
that i get to meet beth and have a a
session they go right it's like the
channel brought me this this was not
part of my plan and yet it delivered
here so
i think the answer is just this is the
practice i have it in my calendar leave
open 20 minutes and trust that it will
come exactly and here's the other thing
you can add into it evan like so this
morning
how i do my little practice it's weird
um but it's mine it's my spiritual like
tantrum is i looked in the mirror and
i'm like i am wildly [ __ ] impressive
here's what i want today i want a little
this i want a little this i want a
little less like so i put out what do i
want
i have no idea if any of it's going to
happen right but okay i want to get a tv
spot i want this i want that right so
far none of that's happened but what has
happened
has already
electrified making a difference so we
never know what's going to happen i did
not know on my call with nick this
morning that something would come from
that i did not know from my call with
this one that something would come from
that
you just don't know you're trusting
that if you're at that high state the
universe will act in kind
and so it's really believing at that
level so it could be like in your 20
minutes evan it would be like oh
what do i want to have happen today i
want garyvee to call me and want to be
on my stage i want like whatever the
freak you want you're playing in
dreaming and what you want not what to
do
what do i desire
so it's really the new thing you're
asking evan is more what do i desire not
what should i do
you go right to do because you're a
master of doing like i am
except our magic and secret sauce can't
be in the doing anymore given what we
want to accomplish it's got to be in the
more of the dreaming state the believing
state the manifesting state the flying
from the top up here out of the world
the unicorn you're already a unicorn
you're bringing the unicorn right and
you don't know you're just in desires
what do i want what do i want because
the universe will act in kind with what
you want
so it's more you're playing in
living up at that level where you
created this whole world that didn't
exist
and how you created it is you were up in
the trees you were not in okay so first
i should open a youtube station and then
i should talk about that no
the dream came first and then you are a
master of doing but you stay there and
you can't have that be your default
state anymore
i like that you called it a youtube
station it's great
i know i'm an idiot i know it's great i
love it no this is great i do i mean i
do a walk outside every morning i go
walk get my coffee uh i i find like
active
i don't i find active like meditation as
opposed to just sitting there and so
this i'll just use that time every day
absolutely and you're in you want i'm
gonna give you another word to play and
so you can keep playing you're it's
almost like
you're in you could create this game of
make believe
so if i were doing make believe
what do i want well i want this company
that my sister's building to sell for
this much money which one then give me
this much money which then i could buy a
fifth avenue apartment blah blah blah in
the make believe world which puts you up
high
so when you're doing your 20-minute walk
for coffee you could be in like the
make-believe world oh you know what they
pick me up they want me to do a tv show
i would that would make a difference i
would get to weigh more people that way
like start to be in your desires of
that not to do's but dreaming and
desires of what does eben want which
brings us right back to what you started
with which is you used to be bad at
asking for things
so the
you're working the muscle of what is
evan desire
that's where you built this dream from
was from your heart not your head and
the doingness i want you back in your
heart in a big way
and then we don't know what's so
exciting about you giving you our
unicorn what you'll create out of being
up there we have no idea it could be
it's going to be way bigger than you
even ever thought
did you get what you want from your
coaching call yeah it was great
i like it
i like it so tell me so now say back
what did you get from the coaching so i
can hear what you got from it
uh a feeling of of gratitude and um
kindness like thank you for spending the
time to
to dig deep and and uh follow my
path and deviate as we went and answer
my questions and like so i'm feeling
grateful to you for that so thank you
and hopefully the audience as well to
watch um
to the validation of what i have been
doing is
is good in terms of tightening the leash
now now i know to tighten it faster and
sooner and how to get out of it and
three that the the state of
abundance like we'll figure out i'll
have to figure out myself like what
actually resonates but
believing in the plan as opposed to
believing in
in the dream
uh
is a is a
moving to that state as default i think
is
that's a big changer so you know again
and then now that circles back to
gratitude like hey thank you for that
for the for the breakthrough there
absolutely i get to give the gift of you
to the world so anything i can do to get
your cavity or pollution out of the way
so you can
um you know you work for god man and you
really do as far as i'm concerned
whether people believe in god or not you
work for a bigger power that you cared
this deeply about humanity and so
anything i can do to give you what you
need to be able to make the difference
you're making rock on
there's um a picture somebody sent me
i'll show you i think you'll like this
so i've got pictures of people behind me
right like steve jobs ap giannini uh my
parents you know that's me but my
parents but somebody sent me this
picture
of of me
as a king
and it makes me feel incredibly
uncomfortable
i look at this like who would like this
feels very egotistical very un canadian
and very uh
i don't know how i was raised right
feels like this is not me but i keep it
here as a reminder of like discomfort in
maybe what i'm trying to build so this
feels like it's kind of
you know this doesn't have to only be
ego it could also be greatness and so
like you're yeah you're pioneering
something into the world that's needed
and that
um
that's a beautiful thing and anything i
can do to help you do that would be my
honor and privilege
let me ask you one last question about
labels and
yeah
uh
i've used labels as an incentive towards
action so i've known that you know i
i've historically been shy and
introverted and anytime i catch myself
saying those things i call them play
bigger triggers
that because i said it now i have to go
do whatever the thing was like if i'm if
i say i'm too shy to talk to beth
because i said that now i have to do it
just because i said that it's a play
bigger trigger i have to go do it just
because
that's smart but yeah so your question
is the question is i've i've flipped
those
labels
into maybe a coping mechanism or using
it as a positive
versus
no labels like to stop identifying even
as an introvert or a former introvert or
whatever you believe you prove
so if you're going you see if a doctor
cuts you open we would not find the
missing part that you don't have that
makes you an introvert versus an
extrovert so it's all bull
it's whatever you believe you prove
so if you're shy and an introvert it
allows you to get off the hook and then
people use that right
um
there's just the honest stuff about it
so there's you can be shy but i would
stop proving that right like if that's
an air it sounds like you've already
handled it um or at least you press
yourself through right so there are
traits that we have
that suck about us i can be a [ __ ] you
know people can be procrastinators
condescending like there's all the
traits that we have that work about us
that are great and that suck they are
you could call them labels but there's
just the honest truth right like yes i
can be a [ __ ] i can totally i'm a great
leader right and i can go through all
the different things it's the ones that
debilitate you or get you off the hook
you want to be watching
so if you get if you keep using i'm shy
and then tell me you know beth i want to
have a breakthrough with having friends
i would then tell you all right we're
going to have to stop with the shy
business and we need to make a promise
to get you to you know
get some friends
right so i would immediately come in and
replace it so it's you know
so
when we say to ourselves i can be a
blank
part of that is you know factual and
like hey now we need to fix this but is
part of that not also like manifesting
more of that because it's a belief that
you can be that
i can tell there's not a question about
my [ __ ] right if you meet my parents
you'll understand right that's where
that comes from but that's not what i
walk around in at all i've replaced it
right and if by exception i [ __ ]
someone you for sure are getting an
apology and an ownership and a cleaning
and a resolution of that
so
if it was
let me see so my um i'm thinking of
something so like my
being boring
right where my sister accused me
basically of being boring and not
producing incredible results based on
who i am yesterday
that then gave me
promise consequence and taking it on to
take that down
so if you're shy and you're that's not
you're going to have to kill that in
order to get your dream then we got to
replace it which is completely you can
change anyone's behavior absolutely
so maybe this ends up like if we take it
all the way down the line maybe we all
become buddha or something but if the if
it's whatever you believe you prove if
you believe that i can be a [ __ ] do you
not then prove that to yourself and do
we not then want to manifest that
that's why it's on a leash i'm not
allowed to be right i have promises
right so it's not anything i have to
work on anymore because it's already
leashed
just like i have leashed um
um
my being fragile or i've leashed um
um
not producing great results or i've
leashed dooms in things no i've got my
personality traits that work about me
and suck about me and the ones that suck
i replace them so i don't
i don't have it be like it's a label
it's just true i really can be
um that girl and i don't want to be that
girl so there's a leash and let's
replace it with this so i'm not stuck
with it i'm not stuck with anything if
it's not working for me or working for
my daughter i'm gonna shift it unless i
tell her too bad you gotta just deal
with it i'm not changing it there are
certain things i'm not gonna change i
eat like a pig
i truly eat like you would not like i
don't have any table manners right and
i'm not changing that and i don't give
and do i eat like a pig absolutely on my
first dates with men i'm like listen let
me tell you some things you're going to
hate about me i eat like a pig and i'm
not changing and if that's a deal
breaker let's not we'll we will be done
after this date right first out bath
could be a great youtube channel
i could
i love to see that'd be great okay so
we're not eliminating the negative
beliefs where no
no we're just they give you what you
then need to do right so
when you see like wow i have someone on
my team i really think is a jerk either
fire then beth or
stop thinking they're a jerk and fix it
and go have the conversation that's my
choice
cool i deeply appreciate the guidance
the wisdom the push for people who want
to dive more into your world yeah what
are they doing you've got you've got
you've got inner you that's more like
group coaching so the best thing that
people could do is just go right into um
you'll have the link at handel group go
follow us on instagram for sure but
there's a current reality quiz that's
free
that will have you see like evan the
areas that you're doing great at and the
areas that you need some work on and so
the current reality quiz is free it'll
be in the link if you want to um you
know get the newsletter that's free rock
on if you want to buy our online digital
coaching program enter you you totally
can it's you know 425 dollars for the
entire coaching program plus a free
coaching session and a free group
coaching session so we make things easy
for people what what a just
break that down a little more what do
what are people get four to 25 bucks
they get a group coaching what's in the
training
yes so either you can buy inter-ulife or
enter you love depending on which part
you're working on it's 425
you get 12 modules
which is about 40 minutes of listening
to the principle of coaching then you
get someone giving you an example of
that principle and then you have the
homework you can listen to it on your
phone
in your car and then the homework's got
to be done right now on the computer
because it's a lot of homework and it's
our complete like if i were if you hired
me to be your
coach
this is the entire coaching program i
would take you through it's like our
textbook um and then what you get for
the 425 besides the whole coaching
program and you get that license forever
it's yours
you get one free hour coaching session
with one of my coaches
and you get a um i think it's four
classes with a group it's called the
master class of taking you through the
first four modules of your interview to
get you engaged in and it's free and
it's with the group and you get all that
for 425 dollars
i love it well we'll link all that up
below so go check out the description um
i've i've talked to a lot of different
coaches over the years and what i do and
and nobody has
has spun me inside out like this
session together so
if you guys are at all curious go check
out the links down below and um i'm i'm
i'm grateful that you came into my world
and that the universe delivered for us
today beth yes for sure absolutely it
was a privilege and maybe we'll do
another one so i can hear how you're
doing soon oh that sounds good sounds
good thank you brad all right bye evan
if you want to see my recent one-on-one
with beth's client garyvee check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i'm talking about
something that the world thinks is a
contradiction i don't understand why
anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an
employee in a meeting ever